sally thank you we want to thank  everyone who sent in pictures of the  damage from last night's windstorm it  was a busy day for mikhail melnow who  owns a tree service sent these pictures  from the west side in summerlin and as  you can see quite a bit of damage i saw  walking out this morning the first two  vehicles i saw were tree trucks  oh yeah yeah overturned trees broken up  limbs you know things a lot of plastic  trash bags we had a little moment of  silence for the tree in the channel lake  parking lot i know also fit the dust  thankfully it fell away from cars and  towards the lawn honestly i'm going to  miss that tree  that was a huge tree and it gave great  shade yes that's what i mean for all  cars  and  tree to get that big it's been taken  it's been years i gotta be honest ted i  didn't know you were that tied to the  tree no i want to explain i really am  you know how many times i've eaten lunch  under that tree right  you always find ted there with his pbj